you all know how much I love scary mazes
in theme park so I just have to talk
about this trailer for Hellfest this is
gonna be a pretty short video though so
just roll the intro okay as soon as I
saw the scene with the hammer I was
thinking it would be really cool if this
was used as a weapon somewhere in the
movie and sure enough at the end of the
trailer here there's a quick shot of the
stalker using it as a weapon I also
thought that the slider being a zombie
head thing was a nice touch and this
could be a metaphor for the point that
we're reaching the maximum intensity in
this movie the friend character has a
lot of this hippie stuff in her room so
I wonder if there's gonna be a scene
where she has a chance to take out the
killer or something and she doesn't
because she's all anti violent I don't
know just a thought I was looking at
some of the themed areas because I love
analyzing that stuff in theme parks I
mean I used to do theme park videos when
I was a kid
[Music]
so there are two areas that stood out to
me the first being this which is maybe
like an evil twist on Alice in
Wonderland with these mushrooms and the
decaying trees back here and then this
guy standing in a big zombie head teacup
thing any announcer is kind of like a
Mad Hatter type of character and then
the other area I thought was interesting
was maybe like a haunted school theme
which I think is a pretty unique idea
you've got a classroom and gym locker
room and a hallway
I like seeing some original teamed areas
that aren't just intellectual property
based but it looks like this movie will
feature some characters who are kind of
like parody horror IPS because they
probably don't have the rights we've got
a few knock cups of saw The Strangers
Beetlejuice predator The Walking Dead
and some that are probably not
intentional but I'm gonna mention
anyways just for laughs
like Argus the earth shapers and wait
this one actually looks strikingly
similar one of the lines and this
trailer gave me an idea roll that clip I
actually like the idea of a theme park
hiring a few character actors just to
stock certain groups for the entire
night like if I owned a Horror Nights
type thing I definitely have like maybe
five to ten actors that I tell just to
shadow the same group of kids for the
entire night it would be way creepier
than any of the mazes I know that's not
what's going on in Hellfest but I just
thought I'd share that idea I think it's
pretty cool like I said not a whole lot
to talk about here so if you're looking
for more content this week I was in a
collab where I play this creepy camp
counselor so go check that video out all
dayit a creepypasta is coming back with
a new episode next week so make sure
your subscribe to see these worlds for
new Horrors every week bring that death
bell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one
assuming we both survive